Hey everybody, how's it going? I know a lot of folks out there ask about AI and machine learning. Patrick's done some machine learning stuff in the health space. I do a lot of machine learning stuff, or at least I pretend to in my day job. And so a lot of people write to us, message us on Twitter, asking questions along these lines. And so it's always a real pleasure where we can talk about an area that we really love. And this is right in the heart of it. We're gonna be talking a lot about machine learning embeddings, which is a term you might not have heard before, but you're going to really enjoy it. And it's something that is extremely, extremely useful.
大家好，最近怎么样？我知道很多人都在问关于人工智能和机器学习的问题。Patrick 在医疗领域做过一些机器学习方面的工作。我自己也做了很多机器学习相关的事情，或者至少在日常工作中是这么装模作样的。所以很多人写信给我们，在 Twitter 上给我们发消息，问这类问题。因此，当我们能谈论一个我们真正热爱的领域时，总是非常令人高兴的。而这正是我们今天讨论的核心。我们将深入探讨机器学习嵌入（embeddings），这是一个你以前可能没听说过的术语，但你一定会很感兴趣。而且它非常、非常有用。
I'm extremely lucky that we have Ido Liberty here, who's an expert in this area. He's the CEO of Pinecone, and he's here to talk to us about embeddings and kind of riff on that. So thanks so much for coming on the show, Ido. Yeah, thanks for inviting me, guys. Cool. So we ask a lot of folks this lately, how has COVID kind of changed your business? Are you back in the office yet? Or what's going on with that? Half are and half aren't. So the California folks are still at home. New York folks are back in the office.
我非常幸运能请到 Ido Liberty 来到这里，他是这个领域的专家。他是 Pinecone 的首席执行官，他来到这里是为了和我们谈谈嵌入，并就此展开讨论。非常感谢你来到我们的节目，Ido。是的，谢谢你们的邀请。太棒了。那么，我们最近问了很多人这个问题，新冠疫情在多大程度上改变了你们的业务？你们回到办公室了吗？或者现在情况如何？一半人回了，一半人没回。加州的员工还在家里办公。纽约的员工已经回到办公室了。
Israel folks are back in the office. Oh, I see. Is that because of local laws or just how people felt in those areas? It's a bit of both. A bit of both. I'm a big believer in people hanging out together and seeing each other and having lunch together and getting to know each other a little bit better than on Zoom. So I'm pushing everybody who wants to be together to be
以色列的员工也回到了办公室。哦，我明白了。这是因为当地的法律，还是因为那些地区人们的感受？两者都有。两者都有。我非常相信人们聚在一起、见面、一起吃午饭，比在 Zoom 上更能增进彼此的了解。所以我正在推动所有想聚在一起的人
together. Yeah. Yeah. Totally agree. Totally agree. I wonder if we'll end up with, remember WeWork? I think is WeWork still a thing? It probably is still a thing, even though they had all sorts of issues as a company, but that might be the kind of thing where physically you're next to a bunch of people that you can socialize with, but you actually all work for different companies or something like that. Who knows what the future is going to be? Yeah, 100%. Cool. So why don't you tell us your story and how you got into this area and how embeddings became important to what you do and kind of where that all started from? Yeah. So my journey into becoming a CEO has nothing to do with business. I did my PhD in computer science and my postdoc in applied math, working mostly on
聚在一起。是的。完全同意。完全同意。我在想我们最终会变成什么样，还记得 WeWork 吗？我想 WeWork 现在还存在吗？它可能还在，尽管作为一家公司他们遇到了各种各样的问题，但这可能就是那种你在物理上和一群人在一起，可以进行社交，但实际上你们都为不同的公司工作之类的情况。谁知道未来会怎样呢？是的，百分之百。太棒了。那么，你为什么不给我们讲讲你的故事，你是如何进入这个领域的，嵌入是如何对你的工作变得重要的，以及这一切是从哪里开始的？好的。我成为首席执行官的旅程与商业毫无关系。我攻读了计算机科学博士学位，并在应用数学领域做了博士后，主要研究
CS theory and algorithms for machine learning and big data. What I ended up doing mostly was high dimensional geometry. So numerical linear algebra and clustering and dimension reduction and stuff like that. And a big part of that was nearest neighbor search and searching through high dimensional vectors, which we will get to in the end or in the middle of this discussion. And then I opened a company in 2009 that did the real-time video search. And real-time video search kind of has to be based on this vector search capability, which we'll talk about later.
计算机科学理论和机器学习及大数据的算法。我最终主要做的是高维几何。也就是数值线性代数、聚类、降维等等。其中很大一部分是最近邻搜索，以及在高维向量中进行搜索，我们最后或者在讨论中间会谈到这一点。然后我在 2009 年开了一家公司，做实时视频搜索。实时视频搜索必须基于这种向量搜索能力，我们稍后会谈到。
And again, so I started investing in that. So can you tell me real quick, this always fascinates me. How did you make that leap to being an entrepreneur? So right before, let's say 2008, what were you doing? And then how were you able to sort of quit that job and say, okay, I'm going to start this real-time video understanding company? What made you take that leap of faith? So the answer is, so it's two things really one of them is uh i've just always kind of been
再说一次，我开始投资这个领域。那么你能快速告诉我吗，这总是让我着迷。你是如何实现从研究人员到企业家的跨越的？就在 2008 年之前，你在做什么？然后你是如何辞掉那份工作，并说，好吧，我要创办这家实时视频理解公司的？是什么让你迈出了那一步？答案是，其实有两件事，其中之一是，我一直以来都
very entrepreneurial but by nature i was kind of i was importing like balance skateboards to israel when i was in high school and i was like i was always like doing stuff like that right so i was some part of it was always a little bit entrepreneurial. But the other one is just like dumb luck and just happenstance. I was in New York and my cousins of all people said, oh, I'm going to start this company and I'm going to hire whatever, like 10 engineers to do XYZ. And I'm like, oh, you don't need 10 engineers for this. We can whip it up in like like like a month and uh
非常有创业精神，但本质上，我还在高中时就从国外进口平衡滑板到以色列，我总是做类似的事情，对吧？所以其中一部分一直都有点创业精神。但另一件事纯粹是运气和偶然。我在纽约，我的表亲们说，哦，我要创办这家公司，我要雇 10 个工程师来做 XYZ。我说，哦，你不需要 10 个工程师来做这个。我们可以在一个月左右的时间里把它搞定，而且
you can you can go raise money on that and he didn't believe me so we we spent a month and we we made something work and so you know when we found ourselves with some money in a company so like okay i guess we have to run a company now. Wow. So you took a month off, like a month. I wouldn't call it a vacation. It's probably like the busiest month of your life, but you took that month off, quote unquote, and then you went to investors and you said, here's our idea. I was a postdoc at the time. So it's like the work was not incredibly demanding, definitely not time critical. So like I could kind of disappear for a month. It was actually a great, like, I loved it. I actually still remember it. I would wake up at
你可以去筹集资金，他不相信我，所以我们花了一个月的时间，我们做出了一些成果，所以你知道，当我们发现自己有了一些资金和一家公司时，就想，好吧，我想我们现在必须经营一家公司了。哇。所以你休了一个月假，就像一个月。我不会称之为假期。这可能是你一生中最忙碌的一个月，但你休了那个所谓的“一个月假”，然后你去找投资者说，这是我们的想法。我当时是博士后。所以工作并不是特别繁重，绝对不是时间紧迫的。所以我可以消失一个月。这实际上很棒，我喜欢它。我至今还记得。我会
like 8am. I would make myself coffee. I would sit down and I would code until like midnight and go to sleep. I did that for a full month. And it was fantastic. It was fantastic. It's so addictive. It's like this dopamine rush, you know? Exactly. I didn't talk to anyone. I didn didn't need anything i would just like drink coffee and coke for like a month straight it was fantastic i loved it not a single meeting man it sounds amazing actually you bring back really really positive memories i mean maybe maybe we should do that again i mean like every now and then maybe highly highly recommend yeah wow that's an awesome story. A month's worth of flow.
在早上 8 点左右醒来。我会给自己冲杯咖啡。我会坐下来一直写代码到午夜，然后去睡觉。我整整做了一个月。这太棒了。这太棒了。这太让人上瘾了。这就像多巴胺的冲动，你知道吗？没错。我不和任何人说话。我什么都不需要，我只是连续一个月喝咖啡和可乐，这太棒了，我喜欢它。没有一个会议，伙计，这听起来真的很棒。你带回了非常非常积极的回忆，也许我们应该再做一次，我的意思是，偶尔也许，强烈推荐。是的，哇，这是一个很棒的故事。一个月的专注状态。
It was fantastic. But anyway, the cool part about it is that we ended up building a really cool solution. We ended up selling the company. I moved to Yahoo when I was there, director of science. So did you sell the company to Yahoo or is that how it worked out? No, no. We actually sold it to Vizio. Okay. Got it. The TV company. And then the company to Yahoo or is that how it worked out? No, no. We actually sold it to Vizio. Okay, got it. The TV company.
这太棒了。但无论如何，最酷的部分是我们最终构建了一个非常酷的解决方案。我们最终卖掉了这家公司。我去了雅虎，当时我在那里担任科学总监。所以你是把公司卖给了雅虎，还是事情就是这样发展的？不，不。我们实际上把它卖给了 Vizio。好的。明白了。那家电视公司。然后把公司卖给了雅虎，还是事情就是这样发展的？不，不。我们实际上把它卖给了 Vizio。好的，明白了。那家电视公司。
And then I moved to Yahoo, where I spent a lot of time as the director of machine learning. So I was building machine learning platforms and solutions and so on, working on mail and ads and spam and feed ranking and so on. And yeah, then went to AWS and spent about two and a half three years so all the all the offerings from aws so sage maker and all the you know there's like recognition i think for video yeah exactly language stuff language stuff all that you know all those services i didn't own all of them but I was definitely a part of building that org and being a big part of the science of a lot of these services. So I, you know, my journey has kind of been a little bit all over the map, which is highly recommended. Seems chaotic in hindsight,
然后我去了雅虎，在那里我花了很多时间担任机器学习总监。所以我当时在构建机器学习平台和解决方案等等，从事邮件、广告、垃圾邮件和信息流排名等等工作。是的，然后去了亚马逊云科技（AWS），待了大约两年半到三年，所以 AWS 的所有产品，比如 SageMaker，还有你知道的，比如 Recognition，我想是用于视频的，是的，没错，语言处理，所有这些服务，我并没有拥有所有这些，但我绝对是构建该组织的一部分，并且在许多这些服务的科学方面发挥了重要作用。所以，你知道，我的旅程有点天南地北，这是非常值得推荐的。事后看来似乎很混乱，
but kind of fun nonetheless. No, I think it's amazing. I think it's great. I think that, you know, you can see the progression. I mean, it's, it might be, might seem chaotic, you know, geometrically, but you can see kind of a, like a nice trajectory. Yeah. Yeah. Very cool. And so, and so you were at AWS and then from AWS, is that how you were inspired to go to Pinecone or was there a spot in between? No, no, from AWS I opened Pinecone. So building, it was kind of seeing how the sausage is made, like building managed services and databases. That's where I really got into like databases and managed services and cloud offerings and so on,
但尽管如此还是很有趣。不，我认为这很棒。我认为这很好。我认为，你知道，你可以看到这种进展。我的意思是，它可能看起来很混乱，你知道，从几何角度来看，但你可以看到一种很好的轨迹。是的。是的。非常酷。所以你在 AWS，然后从 AWS 出来，你是受此启发去创办 Pinecone 的，还是中间还有一段经历？不，不，从 AWS 出来我就创办了 Pinecone。所以构建它，就像是亲眼目睹了香肠是如何制作的，比如构建托管服务和数据库。那是我真正深入了解数据库、托管服务和云产品等方面的地方，
kind of really diving in deep into that. And it suddenly dawned on me, you you know that like i have solved exactly the same problem like 10 times in my career and i always built it from scratch and it was always hard and always like insufficient in the end yeah so i figured we should do it once and for all and like do it right and give it to everyone. Yeah, that's awesome. Very, very cool. Yeah. Fascinating. Yeah. I think it's amazing journey. We can now give kind of an overview of, you know, what that means to, you know, provide sort of a vector database. And so maybe we first need to talk about, about embeddings and where they come from and why we need them. Yeah. So, of the interesting statistics that I uncovered while thinking about opening
真正深入其中。我突然意识到，你知道，我在职业生涯中已经 10 次解决了完全相同的问题，我总是从零开始构建它，而且总是很困难，最后总是不足以满足需求。是的，所以我认为我们应该一劳永逸地解决它，把它做好，并提供给每个人。是的，这太棒了。非常非常酷。是的。太迷人了。是的。我认为这是一个了不起的旅程。我们现在可以概述一下，你知道，提供一种向量数据库意味着什么。所以也许我们首先需要谈谈嵌入，它们来自哪里，以及为什么我们需要它们。是的。所以，我在考虑创办
Pinecon. I had a lot of conviction that this was needed, but I knew embeddings were needed for dealing with unstructured data. So when you look at tabular data, it's very clear how to store it, how to slice and dice into it, how to work with it, because we have 50 years worth of databases developed for it. Yeah. I mean, if people have used Excel and you've done this thing where maybe you have a bunch of columns with data in Excel, and then you want to try to learn a new column.
Pinecone 时发现了一些有趣的统计数据。我非常有信心这是必要的，但我知道处理非结构化数据需要嵌入。当你查看表格数据时，很清楚如何存储它，如何对其进行切片和切块，如何使用它，因为我们有 50 年的数据库开发经验。是的。我的意思是，如果人们使用过 Excel，并且你做过这样的事情，也许你在 Excel 中有一堆带有数据的列，然后你想尝试学习一个新列。
There's a column that has some missing values, and you want to try to guess it from the other columns. That's pretty easy to do in Excel, and you can kind of imagine what's going on there. There's some model that's just looking at a single row and pulling those values and then trying to infer that new column. But then there's a question of how do you do that if it's an image or a video and pulling those values and then trying to infer that new column. But then there's a question of like, how do you do that if it's an image or a video or a website?
有一列有一些缺失值，你想尝试从其他列中猜测它。这在 Excel 中很容易做到，你可以想象那里发生了什么。有一些模型只是查看单行并提取这些值，然后尝试推断出那个新列。但随后出现了一个问题，如果你是图像或视频，该怎么做？并提取这些值，然后尝试推断出那个新列。但随后出现了一个问题，比如，如果你是图像或视频或网站，该怎么做？
You know, now it's totally unclear how to do that. Correct. And this, you know, it extends much more. So it could be like, yeah, those like very complex data types, like images and long text documents and, you know, some like audio recordings and so on. But it could be like travel through a website, like a trajectory through a website or a shopping cart or something else, which is in and of itself like a complex object. It's not like it's not something you can stick in a table in like four columns. Right. And for a long time, it wasn't really clear how to deal with those objects, right? It was like each and every one of them had its own like little
你知道，现在完全不清楚该怎么做。没错。而且这，你知道，扩展得更多。所以它可能是，是的，那些非常复杂的数据类型，比如图像和长文文档，以及，你知道，一些音频录音等等。但它也可能是通过网站的旅行，比如通过网站的轨迹或购物车或其他东西，这本身就是一个复杂的对象。它不是那种你可以塞进表格里四列的东西。没错。而且很长一段时间以来，处理这些对象的方法并不真正清楚，对吧？就像它们每一个在计算机科学中都有自己的一套小
mini discipline in computer science and how to reason about them, how to structure them, how to predict about them and so on. And in the last few years, there has been this movement with deep learning to basically unify this entire paradigm. So basically say, I will use deep learning neural nets, basically, like deep neural nets, right? To take the input in some way and transform it through some layers or through some transformations. And in the end, provide a high dimensional dense vector. So let's say 1,024, an array of 1,024 floating point numbers. But I will train the network such that that vector is somehow semantically representative of the object.
学科，关于如何推理它们，如何构建它们，如何预测它们等等。在过去的几年里，深度学习出现了一种运动，基本上统一了整个范式。所以基本上是说，我将使用深度学习神经网络，基本上，像深度神经网络，对吧？以某种方式获取输入，并通过一些层或通过一些转换来转换它。最后，提供一个高维稠密向量。比如 1024，一个包含 1024 个浮点数的数组。但我会训练网络，使得该向量在某种程度上是对象的语义表示。
For example, I would train it such that if two documents mean the same thing, okay, they talk about the syntopical, they're similar in some sense, then their resulting vectors would be very correlated. Yeah. And then the magic is knowing what that similarity is, right? Or how to measure that. Right. And so there's a whole, again, there's a whole body of literature and a good amount of technical
例如，我会训练它，使得如果两个文档意味着相同的事情，好的，它们谈论的是同义词，它们在某种意义上是相似的，那么它们生成的向量将非常相关。是的。然后魔力在于知道那种相似性是什么，对吧？或者如何衡量它。没错。所以又有一个整体，有一个文献主体和相当多的技术
know-how of how do you take data and produce these embeddings such as they are good. But the fascinating thing is that it's, while it isn't always the perfect solution, it's very often great. And so you can transform images and text and audio and like shopping habits and like your video preferences and pretty much you name it and convert it into this dense vector. And now you can, instead of dealing with these complex types,
诀窍，关于如何获取数据并生成这些嵌入，使它们变得良好。但令人着迷的是，虽然它并不总是完美的解决方案，但它通常非常棒。所以你可以转换图像、文本、音频、购物习惯、视频偏好，几乎你能想到的任何东西，并将它们转换为这个稠密向量。现在你可以，而不是处理这些复杂的类型，
you can now have this embedding. You actually embed. By embedding, it's like you put an item in high dimensional space you you assign a vector to it right so think about a vector as like a point in a high dimensional space that's why it's called embedding and so now instead of talking about documents and semantic similarity you talk about vectors like and angles and distances and and so now it becomes a lot more concrete and a lot more actionable and a lot more something that you can talk reason about and like build for and like code and and systems and not
你现在可以拥有这个嵌入。你实际上进行了嵌入。通过嵌入，就像你把一个项目放在高维空间中，你给它分配一个向量，对吧？所以把向量想象成高维空间中的一个点，这就是为什么它被称为嵌入。所以现在，与其谈论文档和语义相似性，不如谈论向量、角度和距离，现在它变得具体得多，可操作得多，而且更像是一个你可以谈论、推理、构建、编码和系统化的东西，而不是
like it's not an abstract thought anymore yeah i mean if people have seen this visualization where um there's a bunch of points and they all have kind of springs um in between them and then you you run this through some physics model and they all just kind of springs in between them. And then you run this through some physics model and they all just kind of separate and they end up in this like spiderweb kind of shape, right? That's because all the points are kind of repulsing each other. And even though it's only a local repulsion, it creates this really beautiful kind of spiderweb structure globally, right? Because you see this similar with birds, right? Birds have a similar thing where, you know, they have some very simple rules in their brain around not getting too close
它不再是一个抽象的想法了。是的，我的意思是，如果人们看过这种可视化，其中有一堆点，它们之间都有某种弹簧，然后你通过某种物理模型运行它，它们都只是某种弹簧在它们之间。然后你通过某种物理模型运行它，它们都只是分开，最终形成这种蜘蛛网状的形状，对吧？那是因为所有的点都在某种程度上排斥彼此。即使它只是局部排斥，它也会在全球范围内创造这种非常美丽的蜘蛛网结构，对吧？因为你看到鸟类也是如此，对吧？鸟类也有类似的事情，你知道，它们的大脑中围绕着不靠得太近有一些非常简单的规则
to other birds and like staying in a certain position to the bird next to them. And then that ends up with this like beautiful kind of V shape or swarm or things like that. And this is similar where we're doing that, but then some of the points are actually getting pulled together and some are getting pushed apart depending on things we know about them. Exactly. So there were like works from, I think the early 2000s called like self-organizing maps. So maybe this is like ideas if you're older, you know, I don't know, maybe the idea itself, actually, you know what, I think the idea itself is even older. They were like old works, like on MDS, stuff like that, ISO maps. And there was like a flurry of maybe the idea itself actually you know what i think the idea itself is even older they're like
对其他鸟类，并保持在相对于旁边鸟类的特定位置。然后最终形成这种美丽的 V 形或蜂群之类的东西。这很相似，我们正在这样做，但随后一些点实际上被拉在一起，一些被推开，取决于我们对它们的了解。没错。所以有来自，我想是 2000 年代初期的工作，称为自组织映射。所以也许这是像如果你年纪大一点的想法，你知道，我不知道，也许这个想法本身，实际上，你知道吗，我认为这个想法本身甚至更古老。它们是旧的工作，比如 MDS，类似的东西，ISO 映射。并且有像一阵也许这个想法本身实际上你知道吗我认为这个想法本身甚至更古老它们是
old works like on mds stuff like that easel maps and there was like a flurry of works and everything so you would like take things like say i'll take all the people like you know a million people and i'll just look at their social network graph yeah and i'll try to put i'll try to create a like these virtual springs that put people that you know close together physically. So then we try to make them physically adjacent to each other. And if you try to do that in two dimensions, what you get is the map of the US, like if you have one of the US folks. Maybe now with COVID and social networks, maybe that now doesn't work anymore.
旧的工作，比如 MDS，类似的东西，ISO 映射。并且有一阵工作，一切都是如此，所以你会像获取事物，比如我会获取所有人，比如你知道一百万人，我只会查看他们的社交网络图，是的，我会尝试放置，我会尝试创建一个像这些虚拟弹簧，把你知道的人在物理上拉近。所以我们尝试使它们在物理上彼此相邻。如果你尝试在二维中这样做，你得到的是美国地图，比如如果你有美国的人。也许现在有了新冠疫情和社交网络，也许现在行不通了。
But back in the day, it did. Yeah. Or if you imagine doing a two-dimensional embedding on interests, you might have like a little island over here of gamers and a little island of skateboarders. And there might be somebody who's interested in both. And so they're going to be kind of on this sort of inflection point or on the saddle point in between those two clusters. But you'll still have those large clusters. Or maybe you still have those large clusters. Or maybe you'll have another cluster of gamer skateboarders, right,
但在过去，它是有效的。是的。或者如果你想象在兴趣上做一个二维嵌入，你可能会在这里有一个游戏玩家的小岛，还有一个滑板爱好者的小岛。可能有人对两者都感兴趣。所以他们会处于这两个集群之间的某种拐点或鞍点上。但你仍然会有那些大集群。或者也许你仍然会有那些大集群。或者也许你会拥有另一个游戏玩家滑板爱好者的集群，对吧，
if there are enough of them. And that cluster will start having a defined border and pushing the other clusters away. And so, Jay, you end up with these really beautiful behaviors. And when you're done, you have something really interesting. You can draw a little circle on that map and say, everyone here really likes skateboarding. And once you start introducing a whole bunch of other topics and you get to more than two
如果他们足够多的话。那个集群将开始有一个定义的边界，并将其他集群推开。所以，Jay，你最终会得到这些非常美丽的行径。当你完成后，你就有了一些非常有趣的东西。你可以在那张地图上画一个小圆圈，说，这里的所有人都非常喜欢滑板。一旦你开始引入一大堆其他主题，并且你进入了超过两个
dimensions, you can even guess at things that people like that they didn't even know they liked. A hundred percent. And I think in two dimensions, you get pretty limited pretty fast. So two dimensional space is very limited. but when you live in a thousand dimensional space you you get so much more representational power because you can be a skateboarder but in the same thing same time be a dad in the same time be like really into like whatever like anime and whatever like also be like vegetarian i mean and all these things are facets in your behavior and things that you care about and they, they're not mutually exclusive and you know, they're just like a part of you. So you're not, you're not a skateboarder or a vegetarian, you're both. Yeah. So that's how,
维度，你甚至可以猜测人们喜欢他们自己都不知道自己喜欢的东西。百分之百。而且我认为在二维中，你很快就会变得非常有限。所以二维空间非常有限。但当你生活在千维空间中时，你获得了更多的表示能力，因为你可以是一个滑板爱好者，但同时也是一个父亲，同时非常喜欢，比如动漫，无论什么，也喜欢素食，我的意思是所有这些都是你行为和你在乎的事情的侧面，它们不是互斥的，你知道，它们只是你的一部分。所以你不是，你不是一个滑板爱好者或素食主义者，你是两者。是的。所以这就是，
you know, these high dimensional dense vectors can actually like represent something a lot more deep, a lot more rich, a lot more actionable than just like, you know, this one feature or another. Yeah, it's actually, it's that, it's that curse of dimensionality, but actually working in your favor where we're going from two to four dimensions gives you so much more expressibility. And then going to a thousand dimensions gives you, you know, exponentially more expressibility. And it's just amazing what you can represent. I mean, we've seen just unbelievable things with GPT-3 where people have auto-generated websites.
你知道，这些高维稠密向量实际上可以代表比仅仅是这个特征或那个特征更深、更丰富、更可操作的东西。是的，实际上，它是那个维度灾难，但实际上对你有利，我们从二维到四维给了你更多的表达能力。然后进入一千个维度给了你，你知道，指数级更多的表达能力。而且你能代表的东西真是太神奇了。我的意思是，我们已经看到了 GPT-3 的不可思议的事情，人们自动生成了网站。
There's this thing Codex where it auto-generates code. And it's just amazing. And it's all using embeddings. Yeah. And the amazing thing is like, that's how our brain works too. Yeah. So if you think about everything that you remember seeing,
有一个叫 Codex 的东西，它可以自动生成代码。这真是太神奇了。而且它都在使用嵌入。是的。而且令人惊奇的是，这也是我们大脑工作的方式。是的。所以如果你考虑你记得看到的一切，
everything that you've ever seen, the part of the lateral cortex, and pretty much everything, your higher functions in the brain that deal with visual imagery, the input that deal with visual imagery. Okay. The input that they have is not the light intensity on your retina, which you might think is highly related to the actual image.
你曾经见过的一切，侧皮层的一部分，以及几乎所有东西，你大脑中处理视觉图像的高级功能，处理视觉图像的输入。好的。它们拥有的输入不是你视网膜上的光强度，你可能认为这与实际图像高度相关。
Right. Or what's like, what we think about is an image in like as a RGB roster. What your brain gets is the output of the visual cortex, which is an activation of a few million neurons. And that's it. And those activations have very little correlation to the actual RGB values in the image. In fact, we know for a fact they have almost no correlation because when you look at your partner at midnight inside the house or maybe in high noon outside, in terms of colors, it's completely different. It's got nothing to do with each other, right? But to you, it looks exactly the same. The brain just completely changes all the values to make the embedding exactly the same. So you
对，或者我们认为图像是什么，作为 RGB 光栅。你大脑得到的是视觉皮层的输出，也就是几百万个神经元的激活。就是这样。而这些激活与图像中的实际 RGB 值几乎没有相关性。事实上，我们确切地知道它们几乎没有相关性，因为当你午夜在房子里看你的伴侣，或者在正午外面看时，就颜色而言，它是完全不同的。它彼此之间毫无关系，对吧？但对你来说，它看起来完全一样。大脑只是完全改变了所有的值，使嵌入完全相同。所以你
see the same thing. Yeah. I mean, a good example of this is to try to guess at how thick a wall is an interior wall. Now, if, if you're a dad and you're constantly in the attic, you know, fixing stuff, that's different, you know, that's cheating, but like, but like you might look at a wall and say, Oh, that's, that's maybe, you know, half a foot thick. But then, you know, when you actually look at a map, it's like, oh, no, it's like four feet or something like it. So you'll be off by a ton. And yet you're able to navigate around your house, you know, trivially. You know, you don't have a map that is in any way accurate. But you have this really sort of deep, like semantic understanding of the different rooms and where to go. And and so so you,
看到的是同样的东西。是的。我的意思是，一个很好的例子是尝试猜测内墙有多厚。现在，如果，如果你是一个父亲，你经常在阁楼里，你知道，修理东西，那是不同的，你知道，那是作弊，但就像，但就像你可能会看一堵墙说，哦，那，那也许，你知道，半英尺厚。但随后，你知道，当你真正看地图时，它是，哦，不，它是四英尺左右之类的。所以你会差很多。然而你能够绕着你的房子导航，你知道，轻而易举。你知道，你没有任何准确的地图。但你对不同的房间和去哪里有这种非常深刻的、语义上的理解。所以，
my, my older son sleepwalks. And so somehow he's able to sleepwalk down the stairs and into the fridge and like get a stick of cheese. Like, I don't know how he does it, but, but he's able to do that yet. There's, there's that map isn't there. So it's, it's all just these super deep embeddings and, and because everything gets collapsed down to that, in the case of the human brain, you know, million dimensional embedding, it's in a sense, kind of easy to store, right? Because you're putting the same million numbers to hold, you know, everything you see, and to hold, you know, you might have to integrate over them for video, you know, audio might be a different thing, but it's all the data structure, if you will, is the same for everything.
我的，我的大儿子梦游。所以不知何故，他能够梦游下楼梯，走进冰箱，像拿一块奶酪。就像，我不知道他是怎么做到的，但，但他能够做到，然而，那个地图并不存在。所以，它，它全都是这些超级深度的嵌入，而且，因为一切都被压缩到了那个，在人脑的情况下，你知道，百万维嵌入，它在某种意义上，很容易存储，对吧？因为你放入相同的百万个数字来保存，你知道，你看到的一切，并保存，你知道，你可能必须为视频对它们进行积分，你知道，音频可能是另一回事，但它全是数据结构，如果你愿意的话，对所有东西都是一样的。
So that actually, I think you nailed it. I think this is like, it brings a very interesting topic, which is how do you even remember? How do you get, like when your son sleepwalks, so when he looks at a stick of cheese and he knows it's a stick of cheese, or you look at your loved one and they're whatever. A stick of cheese.
所以实际上，我认为你说对了。我认为这就像，它带来了一个非常有趣的话题，那就是你甚至是如何记住的？你是如何得到的，就像当你儿子梦游时，所以当他看着一块奶酪，他知道那是一块奶酪，或者你看着你爱的人，他们是无论什么。一块奶酪。
How do you know that a stick of cheese? No, how do you know it's the same thing? Yeah. Somewhere in your brain, you need to be able to go and match what you have against the bank of gobs of these like embeddings right and say oh this isn't a truck this isn't a tree and this isn't like uh whatever like my grandma and it isn't whatever like a road it's a stick of cheese right yeah and even you know you can see really abstract like uh like post-modern versions of
你怎么知道那是一块奶酪？不，你怎么知道它是同一个东西？是的。在你大脑的某个地方，你需要能够去匹配你所拥有的东西，对抗这些嵌入的库，对吧，并说哦，这不是卡车，这不是树，这不是，呃，无论什么，比如我的奶奶，它不是无论什么，比如道路，它是奶酪棒，对吧？是的，甚至你知道，你可以看到非常抽象的，比如，后现代版本的
chairs and still know right away it's a chair yeah right and so how does that happen you know how do you do that and so if you think about it computers need to do the same thing you know if i generate an embedding for for a sentence right so So we, you know, you might think about, okay, I'm some, whatever. Like I used to work on spam detection at Yahoo, right? So you see an email that looks like some Nigerian prince is trying to convince you to transfer money somewhere.
椅子，仍然立刻知道它是一把椅子，对吧？所以这是怎么发生的，你知道你是怎么做到的？所以如果你考虑一下，计算机需要做同样的事情，你知道如果我为一个句子生成一个嵌入，对吧？所以我们，你知道，你可能会考虑，好的，我是某个，无论什么。比如我过去在雅虎从事垃圾邮件检测，对吧？所以你看到一封电子邮件，看起来像某个尼日利亚王子试图说服你把钱转到某个地方。
You're like, okay, I know this. I know what it is, right? But it's not exactly the same email. Like these scams look slightly different for each other. But any rational person would read this like, oh, I remember this thing. It looks like something else. Because in your brain, you do this matching very easily. But computers don't know how to do this. So for computers, you would pass a different email that maybe semantically says the same thing, but you would get a slightly different vector
你会想，好的，我知道这个。我知道它是什么，对吧？但它并不完全是同一封电子邮件。就像这些骗局彼此看起来略有不同。但任何理性的人都会读到这个，哦，我记得这个东西。它看起来像别的东西。因为在你大脑中，你很容易做到这种匹配。但计算机不知道如何做到这一点。所以对于计算机，你会传递一封不同的电子邮件，也许语义上说的是同一件事，但你会得到一个略有不同的向量
coming out of it. And unlike structured data, when you can do a hash table lookup and just fetch exactly the same key and then get the same value, you don't have that anymore. You just have a vector that's different than anything else you've ever seen before.
从中出来。而且与结构化数据不同，当你可以使用哈希表查找并获取完全相同的键，然后得到相同的值时，你不再拥有那个了。你只有一个与你以前见过的任何东西都不同的向量。
It might be close to other things you've seen before or highly correlated with a small set, but it's not an exact match. And so if you went ahead and tried to code this thing and try to say, okay, now I have a billion, 1,000 dimensional vectors and give me the 100 that correlate the most with it, right? Except for going one by one, computing the correlation and just keeping the top 10, it's not clear what to do. And so now you get into this like really, really rich and interesting like topic in computer science that has to do with like vector indexes and retrieval. And that's, you know, that's something that like gets really deep, really fast. And again, I'm happy to dive as deep as you want. I'm not sure how much you want to, how much you want to scratch the surface.
它可能接近你以前见过的其他东西，或者与一小部分高度相关，但它不是完全匹配。所以如果你继续尝试编写这个东西，并尝试说，好的，现在我有一十亿个 1000 维向量，给我 100 个相关性最高的，对吧？除了一个一个地去，计算相关性并只保留前 10 个，不清楚该怎么做。所以现在你进入了这个在计算机科学中非常、非常丰富和有趣的话题，它与向量索引和检索有关。而且，你知道，那是，你知道，变得非常深，非常快的东西。而且再次，我很乐意尽可能深入地探讨。我不确定你想，你想触及多少表面。
Yeah. Well, let's, let's go through sort of the life cycle of a system that uses vectors, right? So, so let's take like a recommender system, right? So we have, let's say it's an image recommender system. So we have a lot of all of these images and whether the person those embeddings together. And if a person liked one image, but not the other, it's going to pull them apart, right? And there's more complexity around random negative mining and all of that. We'll just leave all that alone and put a bookmark in that. But so you can imagine, you know, in the beginning, it's all random. This is one thing that actually surprised a lot of people. In the beginning, all the embeddings are totally random. This is one thing that actually surprised a lot of people. In the beginning, all the embeddings are totally random. So, you know, for any particular picture, it's just somewhere floating in that thousand dimensional space and every picture is going to have some other spot. But then through this process of kind of pulling and pushing, you know, pairs of points, you know,
是的。好吧，让我们，让我们经历一下使用向量的系统的生命周期，对吧？所以，让我们以推荐系统为例，对吧？所以我们有，假设它是一个图像推荐系统。所以我们有很多所有这些图像，以及人是否将那些嵌入放在一起。如果一个人喜欢一张图像，但不喜欢另一张，它会把它们拉开，对吧？而且围绕随机负采样和所有这些有更多的复杂性。我们只是把所有这些放在一边，并在那里做一个书签。但所以你可以想象，你知道，在开始时，一切都是随机的。这是一件实际上让很多人感到惊讶的事情。在开始时，所有的嵌入都是完全随机的。这是一件实际上让很多人感到惊讶的事情。在开始时，所有的嵌入都是完全随机的。所以，你知道，对于任何特定的图片，它只是漂浮在那千维空间中的某个地方，每张图片都会有另一个点。但随后通过这种拉和推的过程，你知道，成对的点，你知道，
together or apart, you know, eventually it'll start to coalesce into that structure that we really like. And then to your point, if we know somebody, the last picture they liked was this one, then we can ask the question, what should we show them next? And it's, well, what are the closest things to that one they just liked? So now we have this problem of here's a point
在一起或分开，你知道，最终它将开始合并成我们真正喜欢的结构。然后根据你的观点，如果我们认识某人，他们喜欢的最后一张图片是这一张，那么我们可以问这个问题，我们接下来应该给他们展示什么？而且是，好吧，他们刚刚喜欢的那个最接近的东西是什么？所以现在我们有这个问题，这里有一个点
and embedding that we've trained. It could be maybe a week ago, but we have this trained model and we have this point that we know somebody likes. Let's get the points around it. And so, yeah, you're the naive way to do that is to go through every single point and say, how close are you? How close are you? How close are you? And then keep an array of the top 10. But for something like, imagine Amazon. I mean, how many items does Amazon have in their inventory, right? Or how many pictures are on Instagram, right? I mean, just billions. I actually know the answer to that. Oh, really? All right. Let's hear it. If it's not confidential. I think it is.
和我们训练过的嵌入。它可能是也许一周前，但我们有这个训练过的模型，我们有这个我们知道某人喜欢的点。让我们获取它周围的点。所以，是的，你天真的做法是遍历每一个点并说，你有多近？你有多近？你有多近？然后保留前 10 个的数组。但对于像，想象亚马逊。我的意思是，亚马逊的库存里有多少商品，对吧？或者 Instagram 上有多少图片，对吧？我的意思是，仅仅是数十亿。我实际上知道那个答案。哦，真的吗？好的。让我们听听。如果它不是机密的话。我想它是。
Okay. Let's say it's more than 100 billion or something, at least for Instagram. There's so many people on there making pictures. And so that whole idea of going one by one, you just can't do it. So that kind of gets to sort of what you've really been focusing on. And so how do people do that? I mean, Amazon works, Instagram, I can press F5 and it comes right up. Every time I hit refresh, it's right there.
好的。假设它超过 1000 亿或类似的东西，至少对于 Instagram 来说。上面有那么多人制作图片。所以那种一个一个去做的想法，你根本做不到。所以这有点触及你真正关注的东西。那么人们是怎么做到的呢？我的意思是，亚马逊工作，Instagram，我可以按 F5，它马上就出来了。每次我点击刷新，它就在那里。
I PTR, I pull down in the app and I get new photos. Like how are people able to do that in a reasonable time? So now we basically are discussing this like algorithmic question, right? So let's just kind of make that crisp of what the problem is. You get n vectors in dimension d, so n being large, say billions, d being large-ish but fixed, say 1,000. And now I give you another vector in dimension 1,000.
我 PTR，我在应用程序中下拉，我得到新的照片。就像人们是如何在合理的时间内做到这一点的？所以现在我们基本上是在讨论这个算法问题，对吧？所以让我们把问题变得清晰。你得到维度 d 中的 n 个向量，所以 n 很大，比如数十亿，d 很大但固定，比如 1000。现在我给你维度 1000 中的另一个向量。
I tell you, give me all the vectors that correlate the most with it. Or let's just say maybe our closest in Euclidean distance. So I actually measure the sum of squared distances and sum of square discrepancies on coordinates and take the square root of that. So like you said, yes, you can scan everything. Clearly, that's not feasible.
我告诉你，给我所有相关性最高的向量。或者让我们只是说也许在欧几里得距离上最接近。所以我实际上测量平方距离的总和和坐标上平方差异的总和，并取其平方根。所以就像你说的，是的，你可以扫描一切。显然，那不可行。
So now how do you do it? Interestingly enough, you can actually prove that you cannot accelerate this beyond some limit, which is still pretty grim, okay, without incurring some level of error. In some sense, you need to accept the fact that you will have a little bit of approximation. So you might miss something that is relatively close, maybe not almost identical, but kind of on the perimeter of the bowl you're searching in. You might miss that, or you might accidentally include something
那么你是怎么做到的呢？有趣的是，你实际上可以证明你不能在某种限制之外加速这一点，这仍然相当严峻，好的，而不产生某种程度的错误。在某种意义上，你需要接受这样一个事实，即你会有一点近似。所以你可能会错过一些相对接近的东西，也许不是几乎相同，但有点在你搜索的碗的周边。你可能会错过那个，或者你可能会意外地包含一些
that's slightly outside of it. So you have to accept a little bit of a fudge factor, right? But once you do, you can accelerate things significantly. And in fact, all the algorithms that do fast nearest neighbor search do approximate nearest neighbor search. Then approximate nearest neighbor search means look for the nearest neighbors, looks for the vectors that are closest approximately. Approximately means exactly what I said. There's like this little fudge factor around the edges. Now, I'll just kind of give a very quick and
稍微在它外面的东西。所以你必须接受一点点调整因子，对吧？但一旦你这样做了，你就可以显著加速事情。事实上，所有进行快速最近邻搜索的算法都进行近似最近邻搜索。那么近似最近邻搜索意味着寻找最近的邻居，寻找最接近的向量，近似地。近似意味着我刚才说的完全一样。边缘周围有这个小小的调整因子。现在，我将只给出一个非常快速和
maybe almost like a sketch of kind of the main ideas in big algorithms. So, first of all, there is clustering. Clustering is an obvious idea. I'll just start by saying I'll have like a thousand clusters. Clusters are like a
也许几乎像大算法中主要思想的草图。首先，有聚类。聚类是一个显而易见的主意。我将首先说我将拥有像一千个集群。集群就像一个
large collection of points that are all relatively close to one another. And instead of remembering all of them, I'll just kind of remember the center. And so when seeing something, instead of thinking whether it's a mouse or a stick of cheese, I can first say, OK, is this an animal or like an inanimate object, right? If it's an animal, good. I've already reduced the search space by a big margin, right? So now I need
大量彼此相对接近的点。与其记住所有这些，我只会记住中心。所以当看到某物时，与其思考它是老鼠还是奶酪棒，我可以首先说，好的，这是动物还是像无生命的物体，对吧？如果是动物，好。我已经大幅减少了搜索空间，对吧？所以现在我需要
to, and I can iterate on that. So you can like deconstruct the world. That makes sense, like hierarchical, like for Amazon, if you search search for batteries there's probably something in amazon that says this you know don't bother with pet food like just forget that whole category you know like there's there's probably something and then they can do something afterwards right and so but even if you just take images for example even with images you can already take their embeddings and yeah, just already cluster things. Oh, cluster the embedding space.
去，我可以迭代它。所以你可以像解构世界一样。这很有意义，像分层，比如对于亚马逊，如果你搜索电池，亚马逊上可能有什么东西说这个，你知道，不要打扰宠物食品，只是忘记整个类别，你知道，可能有什么东西，然后他们可以在之后做一些事情，对吧？所以，但即使你只获取图像，例如，即使是图像，你也可以已经获取它们的嵌入，是的，只是已经对事物进行聚类。哦，对嵌入空间进行聚类。
You don't have to manually do anything. Yeah, you cluster the embedding space. So now you take those points in high dimension, just say, oh, those set of points are so close together that instead of measuring all the distance, I can just measure the distance of the center. And if it's close enough, then I will maybe suspect that some of them should be close. And then I should check that. So how you cluster exactly and how you then search within those clusters, I still didn't talk about that.
你不必手动做任何事情。是的，你对嵌入空间进行聚类。所以现在你获取高维中的那些点，只是说，哦，那组点彼此太接近了，以至于与其测量所有距离，我可以直接测量中心的距离。如果它足够近，那么我可能会怀疑它们中的一些应该很近。然后我应该检查一下。所以你如何精确地聚类以及你随后如何在这些集群中搜索，我仍然没有谈到这一点。
But that's one main idea that works very well. And again, there's a whole literature on how to do that fast and efficiently and accurately and so on. Then within each cluster, so now let's say you've narrowed down your search space from a billion to let's say 20 clusters, each one of them has a million points. Now they're not clusters anymore because they're all sticks of cheese. Maybe different, whatever. Blue cheese. Yeah, like a piece of chalk and a stick of cheese. And I don't know.
但这是一种非常有效的主要思想。而且再次，关于如何快速、高效、准确地做到这一点，有大量的文献。然后在每个集群内，所以现在让我们说你已经将你的搜索空间从十亿缩小到比如 20 个集群，每一个都有 100 万个点。现在它们不再是集群了，因为它们全是奶酪棒。也许不同，无论什么。蓝奶酪。是的，像一块粉笔和一块奶酪棒。我不知道。
So now, like all white cylindrical things, right? Yeah. So now you really have to do something a lot more refined, right? And there you have a whole other set of algorithms that look like what's called product quantization or other types of quantization, instead of computing the dot product exactly. So saying I'll actually compute the distance exactly for like one candidate and one vector, I will compress it somehow and be able to just
所以现在，就像所有白色的圆柱形东西，对吧？是的。所以现在你真的必须做一些更精细的事情，对吧？在那里你有一整套其他的算法，看起来像所谓的乘积量化或其他类型的量化，而不是精确计算点积。所以说我将实际上为候选者和向量精确计算距离，我会以某种方式压缩它，并能够只
have a very quick, maybe of one, you know, indication of, is this like a likely match, right? So like a real simple way to do this would be just to have buckets, right? So you could just uniformly sort of divide the space up and say, if my point is so many buckets away from this point, then don't even bother, just skip that whole bucket or something. Correct. I mean, buckets actually would be probably more akin to the clustering step. Ah, okay. Got it. Which is a good way, by the way, in low dimensions, bucketing and like an algorithm called KD trees is actually very efficient. If you have an algorithm, if your data is like two or five or 10 dimensional, then this like bucketing works
有一个非常快速的，也许是一个，你知道，指示，这是否是一个可能的匹配，对吧？所以，一个非常简单的做法就是使用桶，对吧？你可以均匀地划分空间，然后说，如果我的点距离这个点有这么多桶远，那就别管它了，直接跳过整个桶或者类似的东西。没错。我的意思是，桶实际上可能更类似于聚类步骤。啊，好的。明白了。顺便说一句，这是一种很好的方法，在低维空间中，分桶和一种叫做 KD 树的算法实际上非常高效。如果你的算法，如果你的数据是二维、五维或十维的，那么这种分桶方法非常有效。
fantastically well. In dimensions like 100 to 1,000, it kind of breaks spectacularly because high dimensional spaces are weird. Yeah, that's true. I never thought about that. But yeah, I mean, just to give a bit of context, like for a KD tree, you can only split. And so a KD tree is a binary tree where at each node in the tree,
效果非常好。在 100 到 1000 维的空间中，它会以惊人的方式失效，因为高维空间很奇怪。是的，确实如此。我从来没想过这一点。但是，是的，为了提供一点背景信息，对于 KD 树，你只能进行分割。所以 KD 树是一棵二叉树，在树的每个节点上，
you split in one dimension. And you say everything that's more than this in that dimension, let's say you split where one dimension. And you say everything that's more than this in that dimension, let's say you split where the fourth dimension is 0.4 or higher. They all go to one part of the tree. Everything else goes to the other part. But because each split is only one dimension,
你在一个维度上进行分割。你说在这个维度上大于这个值的所有东西，假设你在一个维度上进行分割。你说在这个维度上大于这个值的所有东西，假设你在第四维度为 0.4 或更高的地方进行分割。它们都进入树的一部分。其他所有东西都进入另一部分。但因为每次分割只有一个维度，
if you have a thousand dimensions, you can't usually make very good splits. No, I mean, if you split roughly in half, you only have log n splits before you remain with one item in every box. And log n could be like 10, I don't know, like definitely less than 50. And you have 1,000 dimensions.
如果你有一千个维度，你通常无法做出很好的分割。不，我的意思是，如果你大致对半分割，你只需要 log n 次分割，每个盒子里就只剩下一个项目了。log n 可能就像 10，我不知道，肯定小于 50。而你有 1000 个维度。
So that doesn't work. Yeah, so you have product quantization, which is like a very, very quick way of iterating through those candidates. And again, a is like a very, very quick way of like iterating through those candidates. And again, a very mathematical, very, very cool field of research has a lot of numerical and algebra in it and high performance computing tricks. And it's very exciting. In fact, we actually have a paper coming out showing how we beat the state of the art on that coming up very shortly, probably like a month or so.
所以这行不通。是的，所以你有乘积量化，这是一种非常、非常快速遍历这些候选者的方法。再说一次，a 是一种非常、非常快速遍历这些候选者的方法。而且，这是一个非常数学化、非常、非常酷的研究领域，其中包含大量的数值和代数以及高性能计算技巧。这非常令人兴奋。事实上，我们确实有一篇论文即将发表，展示了我们如何在短时间内超越最先进的技术，可能就在一个月左右。
And then there's a whole field, there's a whole other type of algorithms that kind of blend the two and kind of create this graph over your points and say, okay, I'll traverse kind of the map in high dimensional space. I'll have a set of candidates and I'll just look for the neighbor that gets me in the direction that I want to go. And I'll keep going that way. And again, those end up being very efficient sometimes. And sometimes kind of, they just completely choke. And there's a lot of science about why and when that happens and when they excel and when they'll just kind of then the water. I can speak about this for many hours. I highly recommend if you're a computer science major,
然后还有整个领域，还有另一类算法，它们将两者结合起来，在你的点上创建这个图，然后说，好吧，我将遍历高维空间中的地图。我将有一组候选者，我只会寻找能让我朝着我想要的方向前进的邻居。我会继续朝那个方向前进。同样，这些有时也非常高效。有时，它们会完全卡住。关于为什么以及何时发生这种情况，以及它们何时表现出色，何时会陷入困境，有很多科学研究。我可以谈论这个几个小时。我强烈建议，如果你是计算机科学专业的学生，
if you're a mathematician, if you really care about high dimensional geometry, linear algebra and so on, it's a wide and exciting field where a lot of cool things are happening. It's intimately related to how neural nets are applied and how data is represented. So very cool, very cool field.
如果你是数学家，如果你真的关心高维几何、线性代数等等，这是一个广阔而令人兴奋的领域，有很多很酷的事情正在发生。它与神经网络的应用方式以及数据的表示方式密切相关。所以这是一个非常酷、非常酷的领域。
Yeah, totally. Yeah. Yeah, I think that it makes a ton of sense. So the quantization, you're saying that through that, you don't necessarily need a tree. You're able to get it so fast that once you have that cluster of a million items, you can get the dot product or approximation of the dot product of all million of them really quickly. Correct. Wow. That is so cool. I, yeah, for some reason I, I, uh, I didn't,
是的，完全正确。是的。是的，我认为这非常有道理。所以量化，你是说通过它，你不一定需要一棵树。你能够得到它如此之快，以至于一旦你有了那一百万个项目的集群，你就可以非常快地得到所有一百万个项目的点积或点积的近似值。没错。哇。那太酷了。我，是的，出于某种原因，我，我，呃，我不知道，
I totally didn't know that. I thought people were still using KD trees, but you know, your point is spot on. Um, I guess, I guess maybe I guess maybe just to continue the devil's advocacy, what about ball trees or VP trees or these other things? Is the quantization, just the fact that you can parallelize it maybe on a GPU or something, does that make that more appealing than these other sort of tree ideas? Yeah. So there are two factors that play in. One of them is the hardware. Like you said, some algorithms just lend themselves really well to the kind of hardware that you have. So GPUs and so on. And also CPUs, just a memory hierarchy. I mean, the way it's set up, these efficient scans end up being surprisingly efficient.
我完全不知道。我以为人们还在使用 KD 树，但你知道，你的观点非常准确。嗯，我想，我想也许，我想也许只是为了继续扮演魔鬼代言人，球树或 VP 树或其他这些东西怎么样？量化，仅仅是因为你可以在 GPU 或类似设备上并行化它，这是否使它比这些其他类型的树想法更具吸引力？是的。有两个因素在起作用。其中之一是硬件。就像你说的，有些算法非常适合你拥有的那种硬件。比如 GPU 等等。还有 CPU，只是内存层次结构。我的意思是，它的设置方式，这些高效的扫描最终会出奇地高效。
That's one. But the second thing is just like the weirdness of high-dimensional space. As humans, we are limited to thinking about three dimensions. We talk about four and a hundred dimensional spaces, but the mental image we have is really three-dimensional. And high-dimensional spaces are weird. I mean, they are just, they behave mathematically very, very, very different than low dimensional spaces. For example, you can ask yourself how many vectors that are exactly orthogonal to each other I can fit in a space of dimension D. Well, they're exactly orthogonal to each other. And so they form like a coordinate system. Right.
这是一个。但第二件事就是高维空间的怪异性。作为人类，我们被限制在三维思维中。我们谈论四维和一百维空间，但我们脑海中的心理图像实际上是三维的。高维空间很奇怪。我的意思是，它们在数学上的表现与低维空间非常、非常、非常不同。例如，你可以问自己，在一个维度为 D 的空间中，我可以放入多少个彼此完全正交的向量。好吧，它们彼此完全正交。所以它们形成了一个坐标系。对。
And so in dimension D, you can only fit exactly D of those. Yep. What happens if I give you a little bit of flexibility and I say instead of exactly 90 degrees between two of them, you're allowed to have 85 degrees between every pair. How many of those can you put together in dimension D? And so in, or maybe instead of vectors, I think about them as like lines. So they go both ways, right? I only know the answer for two. So in two, you still can do only two.
所以在维度 D 中，你只能放入正好 D 个这样的向量。是的。如果我给你一点灵活性，我说每两个向量之间不是正好 90 度，而是允许每对之间有 85 度，那会怎样？在维度 D 中，你可以把多少个这样的向量放在一起？所以，或者也许不是向量，我把它们看作是线。所以它们双向延伸，对吧？我只知道二的答案。所以在二中，你仍然只能做两个。
Yeah, that's right. And so that didn't change. In three dimensions, you, again, can only do three. I guess so, right? Yeah. And so somehow you would think that it would still grow linearly. And maybe at some dimension, it would start growing a little bit more. But for most people, the intuition is that it would stay somehow linear in the dimension. Yeah. The interesting thing is that it grows exponentially in the dimension.
是的，没错。所以这没有改变。在三维中，你同样只能做三个。我想是这样，对吧？是的。所以不知何故，你会认为它仍然会线性增长。也许在某个维度，它会开始增长一点点。但对大多数人来说，直觉是它在维度上会保持某种线性。是的。有趣的是，它在维度上呈指数级增长。
So in dimension 1,000, you can have more vectors. You can have, I actually calculated once. I forget the number, but it was many billions of vectors that are almost orthogonal to one another. Wow, that is a remarkable, wow. That's mind blowing. I want to really put an exclamation point on that. So everything we're doing is an approximation, right? Everything.
所以在 1000 维中，你可以拥有更多的向量。你可以拥有，我实际上计算过一次。我忘了那个数字，但它是数十亿个几乎彼此正交的向量。哇，那太了不起了，哇。这太令人震惊了。我真的想在这一点上加一个感叹号。所以我们所做的一切都是近似值，对吧？一切。
I mean, even the fact, the way you got these embeddings was through an approximation. You're using some kind of stochastic descent process. And so the fact that you're not a perfect 90 degrees, you're still effectively orthogonal with that tolerance. And so what you're saying is that there's billions of ways things can be just completely different from each other. Yeah. In fact, I'll give you more than that. In fact, if you just take two random directions in dimension 1000, they will be almost orthogonal. Yeah. Yeah, I believe it. Yeah. Actually, that was a method, right? I mean, early on before deep learning, random projections where you just randomly assign vectors to documents, that was one of the ways that people were doing retrieval.
我的意思是，即使是你获得这些嵌入的方式也是通过近似值。你正在使用某种随机下降过程。所以，你不是完美的 90 度，但在那个容差范围内，你仍然有效地是正交的。所以你的意思是，有数十亿种方式可以让事物彼此完全不同。是的。事实上，我会给你更多。事实上，如果你只是在 1000 维中取两个随机方向，它们几乎是正交的。是的。是的，我相信。是的。实际上，那是一种方法，对吧？我的意思是，在深度学习之前的早期，随机投影，你只是随机地将向量分配给文档，那是人们进行检索的方法之一。
Correct. And in fact, my whole PhD was about how to do random projections like algorithmically faster. that makes sense wow that is mind-blowing so oh i see and so then that explains the approximation because i was putting a mental bookmark in that because if you do something like kd trees you can do early stopping like at some point you know that this partition this entire sub tree is further from the nearest neighbor you know even if i was to get the perfect point in this partition, it's still too far and I don't have to search anymore and I'm done. But because we're doing this clustering and because we're, you know, there is a chance that maybe you're in between two clusters
没错。事实上，我的整个博士学位都是关于如何让随机投影在算法上更快。这很有道理，哇，这太令人震惊了。哦，我明白了，所以这就解释了近似值，因为我对此做了一个心理书签，因为如果你做像 KD 树这样的事情，你可以进行提前停止，比如在某个点，你知道这个分区，整个子树距离最近的邻居更远，你知道，即使我得到了这个分区中的完美点，它仍然太远了，我不需要再搜索了，我完成了。但因为我们正在做这种聚类，而且因为我们，你知道，有可能你处于两个集群之间
or something like that. It's just that it's because the clustering is centered around dense areas, the chance that you're not in one of those dense areas is like impossibly small, especially at these high dimensions. Yes. So even though I think, I think the last point you made was actually maybe the opposite of what I was saying. I mean, I think that, you know, you asked about Katie trees and like bowls and so on, just maybe to explain to the audience. I mean, the idea is to say, is to say, okay, I'll have everything in one ball and then I'll just, I'll cover my space.
或者类似的东西。只是因为聚类是以密集区域为中心的，你不在那些密集区域之一的机会小得不可思议，尤其是在这些高维度下。是的。所以即使我认为，我认为你提出的最后一点实际上可能与我所说的相反。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，你问关于 KD 树和球树等等，只是为了向听众解释。我的意思是，这个想法是说，是说，好吧，我会把所有东西都放在一个球里，然后我会，我会覆盖我的空间。
I'll just take balls of radius, like one half. Let's say my, everything lives in a ball of radius one. I'll just cover my data in balls of radius one half, right? So everything lives in there. And then those one half I'll cover with balls of radius a quarter and so on, right? What I'm saying is that in high dimensional data, okay, if you have everything in a ball of dimension one, if you had to cover your data with balls of radius one half, okay, every ball will contain one data point. There would be no tree.
我只会取半径为二分之一的球。假设我的，所有东西都生活在一个半径为 1 的球里。我只会用半径为二分之一的球覆盖我的数据，对吧？所以所有东西都生活在那里。然后那些二分之一，我会用半径为四分之一的球覆盖，以此类推，对吧？我想说的是，在高维数据中，好吧，如果你把所有东西都放在一个维度为 1 的球里，如果你必须用半径为二分之一的球覆盖你的数据，好吧，每个球将包含一个数据点。不会有树。
It would just like everything is far away from everything else, you know? And so there is no tree. There is no structure. It's just random chaos. And whether we like it or not, data is sometimes like that. How does clustering not suffer that same problem? It does. And that's why vector indexes are hard to build because in some sense, they are themselves a model of the data. Yeah. I see. So clustering. Oh, I see. I see. So,
它只会像所有东西都远离所有其他东西，你知道？所以没有树。没有结构。这只是随机的混乱。无论我们喜欢与否，数据有时就是那样。聚类怎么不会遭受同样的问题？它确实会。这就是为什么向量索引很难构建，因为在某种意义上，它们本身就是数据的模型。是的。我明白了。所以聚类。哦，我明白了，我明白了。所以，
so maybe I'll try and get an understanding. So, so, so clustering is, is, is this course thing, but you really only have to do it once. And, and, and within a cluster, there's still many entries versus like this L these tree approaches, you're kind of doing a bad thing many, many times. Like as you're traversing this tree, you're kind of making, you're making log N mistakes,
所以也许我会尝试理解。所以，所以，所以聚类是，是，是这种粗略的事情，但你真的只需要做一次。而且，而且，在集群内部，仍然有很多条目，而像这种 L 这些树方法，你有点在做坏事很多很多次。就像你在遍历这棵树时，你有点在做，你在做 log N 次错误，
you know, until you get to the leaf. Yeah. So, you know, I think, again, it's hard, at least for me, it's very hard to like talk about this abstractly without kind of math and drawings and so on. So, but yeah, it's, I'll just maybe try to wrap it up by saying that it's a fascinating set of problems, which still have a lot of research going into them. And I highly encourage, you know,
直到你到达叶子。是的。所以，你知道，我认为，再次，很难，至少对我来说，如果不结合数学和图纸等等，很难抽象地谈论这个。所以，但是是的，我会尝试总结一下，说这是一组迷人的问题，其中仍然有很多研究投入其中。我强烈鼓励，你知道，
CS graduates and EE and anybody who's like into this thing and want to see some really gnarly math and really cool engineering, it's a good place to put some time in. Yeah, yeah, totally. Yeah, I just want to double down on that. I think it's really interesting. It's becoming more and more important every day. And it's the future of information retrieval.
CS 毕业生和 EE 以及任何对这件事感兴趣并想看到一些非常棘手的数学和非常酷的工程的人，这是一个投入时间的好地方。是的，是的，完全正确。是的，我只是想加倍强调这一点。我认为这真的很有趣。它每天都变得越来越重要。这是信息检索的未来。
It's the future of how search engines and databases will work. And so if you zoom out from the core index, it's like, think about making the analog of databases. We've just spent 20, 25 minutes just talking about B-trees. Or if it's a search engine, we just spent 25 minutes talking about an inverted index, right? But we haven't talked about the rest of the database around it. How do you do the embeddings? How do you save them? How do you retrieve from them? How do you do the OD? Yeah, the management system part of the DBMS. Exactly. How do you update things in place? How do you read and write concurrently? How do you now take this abstract algorithmic discussion
这是搜索引擎和数据库工作方式的未来。所以如果你从核心索引中缩小范围，就像，考虑制作数据库的模拟。我们刚刚花了 20、25 分钟谈论 B 树。或者如果它是一个搜索引擎，我们刚刚花了 25 分钟谈论倒排索引，对吧？但我们还没有谈论它周围的其余数据库。你如何做嵌入？你如何保存它们？你如何从中检索？你如何做 OD？是的，DBMS 的管理系统部分。没错。你如何就地更新事物？你如何并发地读取和写入？你现在如何获取这个抽象的算法讨论
and make an actual hardened production database out of it that you can go and do information, do image search on a billion images in production and not worry about whether it will work or not? Yeah, I actually had two questions which i think will start to get into the management side of it one was how do you deal with the fact that when you retrain the model even on the same data you know unless you keep everything deterministic which is almost impossible if you retrain the model, the embeddings are totally different the next time. And so anyone who's using your database and storing the embeddings, for example,
并从中制作一个实际的、加固的生产数据库，你可以去对十亿张图像进行图像搜索，而不必担心它是否会工作？是的，我实际上有两个问题，我认为这将开始进入管理方面，一个是当你重新训练模型时，即使在相同的数据上，你如何处理这个问题，你知道，除非你保持一切确定性，这几乎是不可能的，如果你重新训练模型，嵌入在下一次是完全不同的。所以任何使用你的数据库并存储嵌入的人，例如，
is going to be in a real big problem when you retrain, right? So how do you deal with that? So, you know, for the listeners, Pinecone, so the company that I founded and ICO is called Pinecone, and it builds a vector database. That's what we do. Okay. The way we deal with this is we give our customers and our users full control over everything. Right. We are not opinionated on like what embeddings you have, where you, you know, how you create them.
在重新训练时会遇到一个真正的大问题，对吧？所以你如何处理这个问题？所以，你知道，对于听众来说，Pinecone，我创立的公司，ICO 叫做 Pinecone，它构建了一个向量数据库。这就是我们所做的。好的。我们处理这个问题的方法是，我们让我们的客户和用户对一切拥有完全的控制权。对。我们对你有什么嵌入，你在哪里，你知道，你如何创建它们，并不持偏见。
And when do you replace what with what. We actually give you full control over your data and how you retrieve from it and what your vectors are. And so we never actually swap your vectors behind the scenes for you. So your query kind of looks one way a second, like a second later it looks different. And you're sitting there thinking what the hell's just happened. You know, if you train a different model and you create different embeddings, then you create like a new vector index in the database, and now you can decide which one of them you want to query.
以及你何时用什么替换什么。我们实际上让你完全控制你的数据以及你如何从中检索以及你的向量是什么。所以我们从来不会在幕后为你交换你的向量。所以你的查询看起来是一种方式，一秒钟后，看起来又不同了。而你坐在那里想，到底发生了什么。你知道，如果你训练一个不同的模型并创建不同的嵌入，那么你就在数据库中创建了一个新的向量索引，现在你可以决定你想查询其中的哪一个。
And maybe you phase one out and maybe you keep both of them or you do whatever you want. And so, you know, as a data infrastructure, we try to be the least opinionated and the most like enabling and just giving all the levers and, you know, buttons possible for our customers. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. I think what you're saying is, again, it raises a lot of other very cool problems. If I just tweak some portion of my data,
也许你淘汰了一个，也许你保留了两个，或者你做任何你想做的事。所以，你知道，作为数据基础设施，我们尽量做到最少偏见，最像赋能，只是给我们的客户提供所有可能的杠杆和，你知道，按钮。是的，这很有道理。是的。我认为你所说的是，再次，它引发了许多其他非常酷的问题。如果我只是调整我数据的一部分，
like do I have to re-index everything? Do I have to, like, how does that work? Do I have access to both versions of the index with some update and some not? If I tell me, oh, I just have all the vectors and I just move each one of them by a little bit. So all the data changes, but not by a whole lot. Do I, can I somehow not just throw everything away and do everything from scratch? There's so much to be done. I mean, this is like, and we've, you know, as a science and as an engineering community,
比如我必须重新索引所有东西吗？我必须，比如，这怎么工作？我是否可以访问索引的两个版本，一个更新，一个没有？如果我告诉我，哦，我只是拥有所有的向量，我只是把它们中的每一个移动了一点点。所以所有的数据都变了，但变化不大。我，我能不能以某种方式不只是扔掉所有东西并从头开始做所有事情？有很多事情要做。我的意思是，这就像，而且我们，你知道，作为一个科学和工程社区，
we're not even remotely close to being able to answer those questions definitively. Yeah, we have something in, so my background is in decision theory, and we have something in decision theory called actor regularized regression, or it could be called critic regularized regression. And what it's basically saying is, let's say it's a robot car. We'll train a model that copies what the robot car is doing right now. So this model, if the robot car maybe is being driven by a person, maybe it's not a robot yet, or who knows what it is, but maybe you have a lot of data of real cars, but we'll train a model that clones that behavior of these people or this past system. And then when we go to train the model that's trying to maximize something, we regularize it, which means we add a penalty the further away it gets from this first model.
我们甚至还没有接近能够明确回答这些问题的程度。是的，我们在，所以我的背景是决策理论，我们在决策理论中有一种东西叫做演员正则化回归，或者它可以被称为评论家正则化回归。它基本上是在说，假设它是一辆机器人汽车。我们将训练一个模型，复制机器人汽车现在正在做的事情。所以这个模型，如果机器人汽车可能正由一个人驾驶，也许它还不是机器人，或者谁知道它是什么，但也许你有很多真实汽车的数据，但我们将训练一个模型，克隆这些人或这个过去系统的行为。然后当我们去训练试图最大化某些东西的模型时，我们对其进行正则化，这意味着我们添加一个惩罚，它距离这个第一个模型越远，惩罚就越大。
And so I could imagine doing something like that, where if you keep your entire neural net that generated that embedding, then the next time around you can add some penalty so that the things won't drift too much. SGD is also like the high dimensional spaces where, you know, that sounds like it makes sense and maybe for 99% of the time it makes sense, but there's still going to be 1% of the embeddings that are going to go to the moon, you know? Yeah, they're going to change completely. And that's, and again, that's, that's fine. You know, what we are trying to achieve is, is kind of make, make that layer as robust and just production ready as possible. So you as a scientist or an engineer in a big company, if you want to do like semantic search over, over, over billions of documents or images or what have you,
所以我可以想象做类似的事情，如果你保留了生成该嵌入的整个神经网络，那么下一次你可以添加一些惩罚，这样事物就不会漂移太多。SGD 也像高维空间，你知道，这听起来很有道理，也许 99% 的时间它是有道理的，但仍然会有 1% 的嵌入会飞向月球，你知道？是的，它们会完全改变。而且，再次，那没关系。你知道，我们试图实现的是，让那一层尽可能健壮且准备好投入生产。所以你作为一家大公司的科学家或工程师，如果你想对数十亿个文档或图像或任何东西进行语义搜索，
you get to care about your application and about, you know, how you retrieve and how you show it to your customers and what they care about, what models you're using and not like the entire, you know, everything we just talked about, like everything, like all the algorithms and optimizations and the hardware and the distribution and the systems design. And there's so much that goes into it that frankly, you, you know, you shouldn't care about if that's not your thing. Yeah. Unless you're me, in which case there is your thing.
你只需要关心你的应用程序，以及，你知道，你如何检索以及你如何向你的客户展示它，以及他们关心什么，你正在使用什么模型，而不是像整个，你知道，我们刚刚谈论的一切，比如一切，比如所有的算法和优化以及硬件和分布以及系统设计。而且其中涉及的内容太多了，坦率地说，你，你知道，如果那不是你的事情，你不应该关心。是的。除非你是像我这样的人，在这种情况下，这就是你的事情。
And it's the only thing you care about. Yeah. So let's dive into that. So there's a bunch of people who are listening to this podcast and thinking this is the coolest thing I've ever seen or heard of in my whole life, right? And so tell us about Pinecone. Are there internships?
而且这是你唯一关心的事情。是的。所以让我们深入探讨一下。所以有一群人正在听这个播客，并认为这是我一生中见过或听过的最酷的事情，对吧？所以告诉我们关于 Pinecone 的事情。有实习吗？
Where are the internships located? Are there full-time positions? What's a day in the life of Pinecone? Kind of run us through Pinecone as a company. So Pinecone, first of all, in terms of locations, we have centers in San Francisco, in New York, and in Tel Aviv, Israel. We certainly have open positions all across the board. I'll just kind of say the three, four most critical areas that we invest in.
实习地点在哪里？有全职职位吗？Pinecone 的一天是什么样的？带我们了解一下 Pinecone 这家公司。所以 Pinecone，首先，在地点方面，我们在旧金山、纽约和以色列特拉维夫设有中心。我们当然在各个方面都有空缺职位。我只是想说我们投资的三个、四个最关键的领域。
First of all is the core engine. A lot of high-performance computing, hardware accelerations, all the index stuff. That sits mostly in Israel. All the cloud stuff that sits mostly in Israel, all the cloud and scaling. Okay, so how do you take those indexes and those data structures and make them scale at cloud, you know, billions of items and be consistent and persistent and highly available and so on. That sits mostly in New York right now. And another thing that sits mostly in New York right now is the management of it. So everything that looks like security, data governance, metering, logging,
首先是核心引擎。大量的高性能计算、硬件加速、所有的索引东西。这主要在以色列。所有的云东西主要在以色列，所有的云和扩展。好的，所以你如何获取这些索引和这些数据结构并使它们在云端扩展，你知道，数十亿个项目，并且是一致的、持久的和高可用的等等。这目前主要在纽约。而目前主要在纽约的另一件事是它的管理。所以所有看起来像安全、数据治理、计量、日志记录的东西，
like all that stuff, right? So everything that makes it a managed stuff, like resource allocation and so on. Okay. And the last thing that we invest in is the action of the machine learning. So the embeddings, the models, the applications of embeddings and vector representations in real life
像所有那些东西，对吧？所以所有使它成为托管东西的东西，比如资源分配等等。好的。而我们投资的最后一件事是机器学习的行动。所以嵌入、模型、嵌入和向量表示在现实生活中的应用
and things like anywhere from recommendation to text, to images, to personalization, to what have you. So it runs a pretty wide set of disciplines and applications, everywhere from low, low level CC plus plus CUDA and so on, all the way up to like modeling and, and so on. Of course, we have open positions, both for interns and full time. Some of them are on our website, pinecone.io. And if you're interested and you're not sure that you appear in those open recs,
以及从推荐到文本，到图像，到个性化，到任何东西。所以它运行着相当广泛的学科和应用程序，从低级的 CC 加加 CUDA 等等，一直到建模等等。当然，我们有空缺职位，既有实习生也有全职。其中一些在我们的网站 pinecone.io 上。如果你感兴趣，并且你不确定你是否出现在那些空缺职位中，
just send us an email. We love hearing from people. Cool. So what's a day like in Pinecone? So what's something that makes Pinecone unique as far as a place to work? Do you have ping pong tournaments or is there something is there something that just kind of organically grew with Pinecone that is has been kind of sticky and interesting? So I I COVID has really threw a wrench in a lot of that, but I will tell you what what I feel I feel is most exciting about working at Pinecone.
只需给我们发一封电子邮件。我们喜欢听取人们的意见。酷。那么 Pinecone 的一天是什么样的？那么有什么让 Pinecone 作为一个工作场所独特的东西吗？你们有乒乓球比赛吗，还是有什么东西，有什么东西是 Pinecone 有机增长的，并且一直很粘人且有趣？所以，我，COVID 确实给很多事情带来了麻烦，但我会告诉你，我感觉，我感觉在 Pinecone 工作最令人兴奋的是什么。
And so I, for better or for worse, we've developed this addiction to like insanely smart, intelligent people. And it makes it very hard to hire people, but most of our folks have either PhDs or high degrees, you know, AWS, Google, Facebook, Amazon, like built huge systems, architected like the internals of AWS and S3 and SageMaker and like Splunk and Databricks and, you know, built unbelievable solutions for like whatever in the load of optimization kind of people who do like crazy just do crazy things i mean like simd and all these things yeah i've been in and around engineers my entire life and like the the sentence uh oh i just made something like 3x faster is being said pretty casually nice that. That's amazing. What happens? Like, oh, I did this and that.
所以，我，无论好坏，我们已经对像极其聪明、有才华的人产生了这种瘾。这使得招聘人变得非常困难，但我们的大多数员工要么拥有博士学位，要么拥有高学位，你知道，AWS、谷歌、Facebook、亚马逊，像构建了巨大的系统，架构了像 AWS 和 S3 和 SageMaker 和 Splunk 和 Databricks 的内部结构，你知道，为像优化负载中的任何东西构建了令人难以置信的解决方案，像做像疯狂的事情的人，我的意思是像 SIMD 和所有这些东西，是的，我一生都在工程师周围，像那句话，呃，我刚刚让某样东西快了 3 倍，说得相当随意，不错。那太棒了。发生了什么？比如，哦，我做了这个和那个。
I changed here and I reorganized all of that. It's like, oh, now it's much faster. Oh, shit. I had no idea that was possible. So you work just with people who just kind of mess with your brain. They're so smart and so talented. And it's just fun.
我在这里做了更改，我重组了所有这些。就像，哦，现在它快多了。哦，该死。我不知道那是有可能的。所以你只是和那些只会弄乱你大脑的人一起工作。他们太聪明、太有才华了。这很有趣。
And at the same time, it's just like I said, the problem itself is cool because it runs all the way from data and machine learning to like big gnarly systems designed to low level algorithms and kind of the whole thing
与此同时，就像我说的，问题本身很酷，因为它从数据和机器学习一直运行到像大型棘手的系统设计到低级算法，而且整个事情
needs to work as one unit. And so you kind of have to be very broad to really get it. And so it's just fun. It's just a fun place to work. That makes sense. And I just wanted to end on this note. Who are the kinds of people who use something like this?
需要作为一个单元工作。所以你必须非常广泛才能真正理解它。所以这很有趣。这只是一个有趣的工作场所。这很有道理。我只是想以这一点结束。谁是使用这种东西的人？
I think some people might look at this and say, well, there's maybe a handful of companies in the world that have a billion images, right? But clearly, even people who don you know, people who have, who don't have maybe that much data, you know, it's not just about not using a for loop. It's about the true management. I mean, you could use a CSV instead of MySQL, if you don't have a big company, it doesn't mean that's a good idea, right? And so give us an idea of like, who is the sort of target audience for this? And like, kind of how broad is that audience and what are the different verticals there?
我想有些人可能会看这个并说，好吧，世界上也许有少数几家公司拥有十亿张图像，对吧？但是显然，即使是那些没有，你知道，拥有，你知道，没有那么多数据的人，你知道，这不仅仅是关于不使用 for 循环。这是关于真正的管理。我的意思是，如果你没有大公司，你可以使用 CSV 而不是 MySQL，这并不意味着这是一个好主意，对吧？所以给我们一个想法，比如，谁是这个的目标受众？以及，那种受众有多广泛，那里有哪些不同的垂直领域？
Yeah. So it's, it's incredibly broad. I mean, uh, you can, uh, like you said, I mean, the fact that you don't have billions of objects, right. Even if you have 10 million objects, you know, it doesn't mean you have to start building a microservice for it. And the beautiful thing about consumption-based pricing for Pinecone is that you pay for what you use. And so if you have a small use case, it's going to cost you like 50 bucks a month. So why are you even bothering? So there's the whole management aspect of it,
是的。所以，它，它非常广泛。我的意思是，呃，你可以，像你说的，我的意思是，你没有数十亿个对象的事实，对吧。即使你有 1000 万个对象，你知道，这并不意味着你必须开始为它构建微服务。而 Pinecone 基于消费的定价的美妙之处在于你为你使用的东西付费。所以如果你有一个小的用例，它一个月只会花费你 50 美元。所以你为什么要费心呢？所以有它的整个管理方面，
which makes it like you get all the bells and whistles, but you just get the hassle-free experience. And that is already a big enough market. But you get two different kinds of scaling issues that look very different systems-wise. One of them is just companies who have an unbelievable amount of data. So they come to us and say, oh, I have 10 billion items. What the hell do I do now? It doesn't fit anywhere. It's just going to cost me
这使得它就像你得到了所有的铃声和哨声，但你只是得到了无忧无虑的体验。而那已经是一个足够大的市场了。但你得到了两种看起来系统方面非常不同的扩展问题。其中之一只是拥有令人难以置信的数据量的公司。所以他们来找我们说，哦，我有 100 亿个项目。我现在该死地做什么？它不适合任何地方。它只会花费我
an arm and a leg to run anything. And companies who have a different scaling issue say, I have 10,000 queries per second. What the hell am I doing? What do I do with this? So Say I have 10,000 queries per second. What the hell am I? What do I do with this? So now I have this super high availability, low latency system that I have to build. So I have to care about a whole different set of problems. So being able to cater to all three is hard and exciting. And for somebody like me, who that's what I do for a living, that for me is a worthwhile challenge. But, you know, those, you know, kind of three buckets are each and every one of them contains thousands of applications and different use cases. And so you don't have to be in Pinterest or Facebook or Google to be facing these issues.
一大笔钱来运行任何东西。而拥有不同扩展问题的公司说，我有每秒 10,000 次查询。我到底在做什么？我该怎么处理这个？所以说我有每秒 10,000 次查询。我到底在做什么？我该怎么处理这个？所以现在我有了这个超高可用性、低延迟的系统，我必须构建它。所以我必须关心一套完全不同的问题。所以能够迎合所有这三者既困难又令人兴奋。对于像我这样的人，这就是我谋生的方式，对我来说，这是一个值得的挑战。但是，你知道，那些，你知道，三种桶中的每一个都包含数千个应用程序和不同的用例。所以你不必在 Pinterest 或 Facebook 或 Google 才能面临这些问题。
Yeah, I mean, one thing you hit on that I didn't think about until you mentioned it was the SLA, you know, the latency. Because I think with PyTorch and TensorFlow and some of these things, you know, you can do vector math without, like, I don't know anything about CUDA or OpenCL, or I've just heard these names, but I'm using PyTorch and it can do the job well. But I think that PyTorch is not designed for low latency. And so if you have a million embeddings in PyTorch, you're stuck. Like there is nothing that you can really do. You have to go outside of PyTorch to do that. Yeah, so you have to use something that's dedicated for it. And you have to optimize all the system around for it. I mean, we have POCs running
是的，我的意思是，你提到的我没有想到的一件事是 SLA，你知道，延迟。因为我认为使用 PyTorch 和 TensorFlow 和其中一些东西，你知道，你可以做向量数学，而不需要，我不知道关于 CUDA 或 OpenCL 的任何事情，或者我只是听说过这些名字，但我正在使用 PyTorch，它可以很好地完成工作。但我认为 PyTorch 不是为低延迟设计的。所以如果你在 PyTorch 中有一百万个嵌入，你就被困住了。就像没有什么你真正能做的。你必须走出 PyTorch 才能做到这一点。是的，所以你必须使用专门用于它的东西。而且你必须优化周围的所有系统。我的意思是，我们有 POC 正在运行
with customers who use a lot more than 10,000 words per second. And they see a 15 millisecond P99. Wow. Wow. It's amazing. And then, so for that, to get that, you have to, it's like the algorithms and so on, but you have to optimize, you know, even like the way you deserialize JSONs. I mean, you can't be careless about that. You know, it's like stuff like that you don't necessarily think about. So it's like everything around it needs to be super optimized for this use case, you
与使用每秒超过 10,000 个词的客户。他们看到了 15 毫秒的 P99。哇。哇。这太神奇了。然后，所以为了得到那个，你必须，它是像算法等等，但你必须优化，你知道，甚至像你反序列化 JSON 的方式。我的意思是，你不能对此粗心大意。你知道，就像你未必会想到的那种事情。所以它就像它周围的一切都需要为这个用例进行超级优化，你
know. One last thing, actually, this is just, I don't want to get too much in the weeds here, but, you know, like with MySQL, you know, people do an insert statement and it seems kind of, you know, you're inserting these tuples. And so it kind of makes sense. So in your case, how do people dump, you know, a billion embeddings into your database? I mean, is like, I guess the API is, it's still like a rest call call with a huge object that's attached to it or something. I mean, you don't send all a billion in one go. You probably would.
知道。最后一件事，实际上，这只是，我不想在这里陷入太多的杂草中，但是，你知道，像 MySQL，你知道，人们做一个 insert 语句，它看起来有点，你知道，你正在插入这些元组。所以它有点道理。所以对你来说，人们如何将十亿个嵌入转储到你的数据库中？我的意思是，我猜 API 是，它仍然像一个带有巨大对象的 rest 调用，或者类似的东西。我的意思是，你不会一次发送所有十亿个。你可能会。
You batch it and you send them in batches of a thousand or you dump them on disk on S3 or GCS somewhere. Oh, that makes sense. So you have this S3 file that's massive that has all these embeddings and you just point PyCon to it. It's like hey go go digest this entire thing yeah that makes sense or you can you can do it on the fly you can do it like you know you have a dynamic API you just observe and update vectors like one by one or in batches oh that makes sense like people are adding new products and so you're adding adding deleting updating so on yeah so there's this like you're adding, deleting, updating, so on. Yeah. So there's this like, you're adding new products, adding new products, adding new products.
你批量处理它，你以一千个为一批发送它们，或者你把它们转储到 S3 或 GCS 上的磁盘上。哦，这很有道理。所以你有这个巨大的 S3 文件，它有所有这些嵌入，你只是把 PyCon 指向它。就像嘿，去消化整个东西，是的，这很有道理，或者你可以，你可以即时做，你可以做，你知道，你有一个动态 API，你只是观察和更新向量，一个接一个或分批，哦，这很有道理，就像人们正在添加新产品，所以你正在添加、删除、更新等等，是的，所以有这个像你正在添加、删除、更新等等。是的。所以有这个像，你正在添加新产品，添加新产品，添加新产品。
And then boom, there's like a new embedding model. Everything has to get rewritten. So there's like now sort of this other snapshot that's being spun up. And then when that's ready, you flip them over. And then, yeah, I mean, this is stuff that you do not want to do yourself. I've never done it. It just sounds it just sounds brutal just talking about it i mean it sounds like a really exciting but hard to do
然后砰，有一个新的嵌入模型。所有东西都必须被重写。所以现在有某种其他快照正在启动。然后当它准备好时，你翻转它们。然后，是的，我的意思是，这是你不想自己做的事情。我从来没做过。光是谈论它听起来就很残酷，我的意思是，它听起来是一个非常令人兴奋但很难做到的事情
yeah exactly and we're not even scratching the surface you know i again i think uh anybody who's built a distributed system like you you think you think about everything and then a customer comes to you with like a mind bender and like, oh, crap. Yeah. Like they want to do what? So. Yeah. Cool. This is really, really awesome. So we have a link to Pinecone in the show notes. People check that out. Is there a free version for people like high school students or college students or, you know, how can they get started with it so first of all uh they can go to our website and they can start a free trial the free trial right now is is uh two weeks and so uh it's not a whole lot of time but if you're if you're a student and you're working on a cool project and you want that extended just drop me a note or whatever we have a chat cool drop us a note and say,
是的，完全正确，我们甚至还没有触及表面，你知道，我再次，我认为呃任何构建过像你这样的分布式系统的人，你认为你考虑了一切，然后一个客户带着一个令人费解的问题来找你，就像，哦，该死。是的。就像他们想做什么？所以。是的。酷。这真的，真的太棒了。所以我们在节目说明中有一个指向 Pinecone 的链接。人们去看看。对于像高中生或大学生这样的人，是否有免费版本，或者，他们如何开始使用它，所以首先呃他们可以去我们的网站，他们可以开始免费试用，免费试用现在是两周，所以呃这不是很多时间，但如果你是学生，你正在做一个很酷的项目，你想延长它，只需给我发个便条或什么，我们有一个聊天，酷，给我们发个便条说，
hey, I'm a student. I'm not really a customer, but I just really think it's neat. Can I keep using it? Odds are, if you really do something cool, we'll just let you do it. Cool. That is amazing.
嘿，我是学生。我不是真正的客户，但我只是觉得它很整洁。我可以继续使用它吗？很有可能，如果你真的做了一些很酷的事情，我们只会让你做。酷。那太神奇了。
We've done that before. So we're all into education and supporting people's learning. Kind of, yeah, Tinker has been building exciting demos. So we're all into education and supporting people's learning. Yeah, Tinker has been building exciting demos. Very, very cool. Yeah, if people build anything really cool with Pinecone, let us know. Let Ido know. We'll have his contact, his Twitter, et cetera, the handle for Pinecone in the show notes.
我们以前做过。所以我们都致力于教育和支持人们的学习。某种程度上，是的，Tinker 一直在构建令人兴奋的演示。所以我们都致力于教育和支持人们的学习。是的，Tinker 一直在构建令人兴奋的演示。非常，非常酷。是的，如果人们用 Pinecone 构建任何真正酷的东西，让我们知道。让 Ido 知道。我们会在节目说明中提供他的联系方式、他的 Twitter 等等，Pinecone 的句柄。
Thanks, everybody, for supporting the show on Patreon. We really appreciate that. And thanks for supporting us on Audible if you do that. And thank you, Ido, so much. This was an amazing episode. There's so much more depth we could go into. We could spend a whole day
感谢大家在 Patreon 上支持这个节目。我们真的很感激。感谢你们在 Audible 上支持我们，如果你这样做的话。非常感谢你，Ido。这是一个很棒的剧集。我们可以深入探讨的内容还有很多。我们可以花一整天
talking about embeddings. We didn't even get a chance to talk about the sort of machine learning part and ResNet and all of that. But, you know, that's, that's, we've did, we've done a really good job of covering, you know, the high level and folks can definitely, you know, look up some of the things that we talked about and take it to the
谈论嵌入。我们甚至没有机会谈论机器学习部分和 ResNet 以及所有这些。但是，你知道，那是，那是，我们已经做得很好，涵盖了，你知道，高水平，人们绝对可以，你知道，查找我们谈论的一些事情并将其提升到
next level. Thank you so much. Thank you. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下一个水平。非常感谢。谢谢。音乐由 eric barn dollar 提供，Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发，你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须提供对 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。此剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。